There are a lot of ways you can
establish status over another man,
like Jorge. A firm handshake.
Displays of wealth.
And feats of strength.
*Groan* Interesting.
Moving that rug was the hardest thing
in the world for you when I needed to
practice tap dancing.
There are also more subtle moves, what I
call microaggressions.
Call them by the wrong name.
Throws them off the moment he meets
you. You must be Huevos!
Jay. Pleasure.
Jorge De la Selva.
In English, it's George of the jungle,
so I stick with Spanish.
Hey, who's got the great taste?
That'd be me.
Ha ha! Nice.
Uh, hello. So you and Gloria used to.
Yep. Ooh.
Hey. So he was a little more handsome
than you were expecting, but pull
yourself together, man.
So, Jorge, you were Gloria's boyfriend
right before Javier?
Yeah, And a little during, you know, she
kind of bounced around between the two
of us. Where is she, anyway?
I got to be at a Dodger game in an
hour.
Oh, you like sports?
That's fantastic.
I try to get this one into baseball.
No-go.
Actually, I hate baseball.
I'm here to sing the national anthem.
I'm an opera singer.
I just finished two months at La Scala.
The house that Toscanini built?
Yeah, well, it's been rebuilt a few
times. You know, a bunch of opera
singers prancing around.
It takes its toll on the foundation.
Yeah.
Hey, I'm here to pick up Mom's old
boombox from storage.
She needs it for...
How many nannies do you see through
these things?
That's Gloria's ex-boyfriend.
Wait, how far ex?
Roughly 20 years.
Oh, my God. Is it possible?
What does Gloria say?
She hasn't even seen him yet.
The odd bit is these two clones don't
see the resemblance. Maybe she won't
either. I'm not going to force it on
her. I mean, it's no easy thing to say.
Is there a chance you're so dumb you
don't even know who the father of your
baby is?
We could do a DNA test.
I could do one at the lab at school,
and then you would have a definitive
answer. If it comes back negative, you
don't even really have to tell Gloria.
Well, what do you need? Saliva?
We take these two down to the Sizzler
and your squeegee, which you need off
the salad bar window.
We use hairs now.
Good. You're home.
One second. Papi, you look great in
that new shirt.
So handsome.
Hey Gloria.
Oh, I thought you were Manny.
Good. You're caught up now.
I know I put on a few, but they don't
take you seriously as an opera singer
when you're too skinny.
You know what happens when the thin
lady sings? The show just keeps going.
It's so wonderful to see you.
I'm going to go and open a bottle of
wine. Do you think that Jorge could be?
Jorge mentioned you bounced around
between him and Javier.
How much bouncing did you do?
Technically, it's possible.
Oh, my God.
How is Manny going to handle this?
Not great! You know, he doesn't respond
well to surprises.
Remember how upset he got when he found
out those mashed potatoes were really
just whipped cauliflower?
What are we
going to do?
Okay, Grandpa I got.
.. Oh, Gloria, you're here.
What do you
bring with you besides that guilty look?
Okay, In order to get a definitive
answer, I had Alex perform a DNA test.
You got them both to spit?
They use hair now.
Hey, lotion is on the sink, Jorge.
Hey, Turns out I'm not the only one who
suffers from dry navel.
Uh, Alex, why do you have a medical
form with my name on it?
I don't think I should be the one to
explain this.
Manny, as you know, your mother and
Jorge had a relationship.
You're a lot alike.
And it made us curious as to whether
Uh, are you saying this is a DNA test?
Your mom didn't even find out until
today.
Oh, I don't even know how to react.
So my whole childhood was a lie.
I thought Javier was my dad.
Now he's just some stranger who gave me
baths. Listen, buddy.
It's not who brings you into the world.
It's what you do when you're there.
You're not Javier.
You're not this guy. You're you.
And what you are is amazing.
And for the record, I've been your dad
since you were ten. And I'm going to be
your dad until I'm gone.
I love you. And I always will.
I love you, too, Jay.
Ha,ha ha.
April Fools, huh?
Now, who doesn't understand a joke?
What? I never dated Jorge.
He's the butcher at the grocery store.
I just thought that he looked like
Manny.
Why would you do that?
Because you said that I didn't
understand funny.
I didn't know you were going to take the
prank this far. You made Grandpa cry.
I know. He was like, "I love you.
And I Always will"